At 3:00 in the morning,
I didn't know he was sending me to get
on at first.
The setup for this is that is that his
limo driver says he's got to stop
somewhere,
so he stops in the ghetto.
It's Dave in the ghetto.
In a limo.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Huh.
That's it.
But the thing is that you do exactly
what I what a honky would do in the
ghetto.
Right?
Right.
And I was crack the window a little bit.
The job starts out in a limousine.
I knew he was taking to the ghetto
because I'm looking out the window.
I'm like gunstock,
snow and snow.
So.
Okay.
There's a little statement,
but it's not preachy.
It's not painting the picture.
Paint a picture.
Right.
Then we get to the ghetto.
That was in Washington.
I saw some kids running around playing
and I was like,
who has the kids just running out on the
streets like this and this.
Maybe it could be in trouble.
He might need my help.
I got to do something,
but I wasn't gonna get out the car.
Okay.
True Story.
Now did the baby talk to me?
No,
was was selling weed.
what?
I was making a point and here I am a
black man in a limousine,
now we're getting into the class issues
right in the ghetto.
So it's true than just I pride myself on
saying real shit that people don't even
notice I'm saying,
but they feel it because when people
come up to me,
they they say that I love.
I love that they can feel it,
but I don't think they really know.
So when you pointed that out,
I was very impressed.
Man.
Was your early comedy autobiographical?
It's yes,
but never directly.
I don't want to give away my secret
recipe.
Want to know what happened to me
on the new season of the sopranos or the
Dave Chappelle,
so received.
If the $5,000,000
shit on TV
though
Chappelle supposedly had it all,
a $50,000,000 contract from comedy
central,
a hit TV show,
best selling dvds on April 28th of last
year.
Dave abruptly walked away not only from
the set of the show but for $50,
million dollars,
which he left his fans shock and most
everyone completely puzzled.
One of the most promising comedians of
recent history have left a successful
television series.
How could he have walked away from a
$50,000,000 contract?
Hey,
where do you start telling them this
story and when I'm walking down the
street and be like,
Hey,
this right.
You tell it how it is.
Not really.
I don't really know what it is.
I just say what it feels.
I'll tell you what happened,
but I can't say it directly.
There's a book
to me that encapsulates my entire
experience before I left the show.
In the book is called Pimp,
written by a black American who was a
pimping the forties.
He describes in detail how these men
break women so that they will give them
the money that they make with their own
bodies because a guy that generates
money,
people have a vested interest in
controlling.
There's a story in his so cold.
It makes me shudder to think about it.
The iceberg slim is trying to control
the woman that he finds uncontrollable.
I will go to work on this show and I
felt awful.
Every day felt like some kind of
prostitute or something like that,
but I feel so bad.
Why keep showing up to this place?
So he asked older how it can rein her in
and the older pimps says,
oh,
that's easy iceberg.
All you have to do is beat that bitch
with a coat hanger.
I felt like,
you know,
in a lot of instances I was deliberately
being put the stress and then run her
bath and give him some pills.
Have you tried to get me to take
psychotic medication?
She'll be so grateful that you fixed the
shoe for good.
You will the motherfucker that beat them
in the first place.
I forgot the hostility of the
environment of Showbiz.
Maybe there's something else going on.
Maybe these rapes aren't even the worst
of it.
Wouldn't that be something?
Now?
End of this book,
Iceberg Slim tells the story is kind of
the crescendo of the book iceberg.
Slim's bottom bitch is at the end of a
mileage.
Choose bubbling.
You could see she was going crazy.
They had to let it go.
It's hard to let it go,
a bottom bitch go and he wasn't ready to
let it go because it's organization
couldn't handle losing her for days
released and it fits all these
incredible records.
Know like how many central was a hot
place to be.
When I showed up there,
he said,
okay,
this guy in an hotel across the street,
it's waiting for you in room number
seven when should go over there and I
want you to fuck them,
but before you do and he to put some of
this stuff in this drink.
I slept a small vial of mineral oil into
her poem.
I told her it was chloral hydrate,
only two drops.
We're not to suck out.
She said,
I did everything you said,
but.
But then Mandel look right some wrong.
Daddy,
do you mean something's wrong?
Bitch?
Did you put that stuff in his drink?
She said,
I did everything.
He said that I put all of it in his
drink.
He said,
wait a minute,
bitch,
wait a minute.
You put all of it in his drink.
I knelt beside him,
blocking her view with my back.
I wiped my brow and turned my face to
water.
My eyes were wide and alarm.
I said,
baby,
he's dead.
I think.
All right,
bitch.
Let me think.
I can fix this for you.
She squeezed tightly against me.
I kept telling her she had nothing to
worry about.
After all,
we went together for life and her secret
would always be safe with me.
She found out about the hoax years
later.
That's how the whole shit works.
Ladies,
you understand?
This bitch was at the end of the
mileage.
She was at four 98.
She ended up triggering for iceberg for
another six months.
She must have done another 200 tricks
for them.
Do you understand?
No like the whore that they turned us
into,
jumped on that plane and left my
father's bedside,
which are granted his day and I went out
and I sat with these people in this room
and
you got to make them have hard and fast
to stick them for the long scratch.
Quip.
So slim,
be as sweet as scratch.
No sweeter and always stick a hole for
bundle before you sexy.
Oh,
Ho ain't nothing but a trick to a pimp
whole Dave chappelle thing is going to
end,
but I feel like I'm going to be some
kind of parable by either what you're
supposed to do with what you nasty.
Well,
I'm going to be something.
I'm either going to be a legend or just
that tragic story,
but I'm going full throttle.
I'm going on way.
I want to.
I'm.
I'm eager to find out how this will
resolve itself.
The idea of being courageous is that
even though you're scared,
you just do the right thing.
Anyway,
so in 2004,
I walked away from $15,000,000 and in
November I made a deal for $60,000,000.
Are you having fun this time around?
I am making a point to have fun in the
store.
Yes.
This video took tons of editing tricks
to carefully assembled these interviews
in a seamless way.
If I didn't know a handful of shortcuts,
it would have taken significantly longer
and I would've wasted tons of time.
The best way to get started on any
editing software,
it's definitely a tutorial that will
teach you how to edit efficiently,
like the high quality tutorials on
skillshare.
Skillshare has over 20,000 classes on
everything from photography to business,
and that includes a final cut pro class
that goes over the fine details of
editing the first 500 people to click on
the link in the description below can
get two months of completely free access
to skillshare.
That includes video editing,
tutorials and thousands of others and
financing,
Photography and cinematography.
Thanks for watching.